[موسيقى]
من زمان كنت تحس انه في نوع فن بده يوصل
له شي عشره 15 سنه كان بباريس بساحه ممارت
وكل الرسامين بيكونوا هناك قعدت حد واحد
هيك وعم بشوف شو عم يقدر يعمل مضيت يمكن
نص نهار وكتير عجبني هالشي خلصت رجعت على
لبنان جبت العده وجبت كل شيء لازم بلشت
اول مره اول لوحه كانت شويه بحر جبلين
وراء وباخره طلعت مثل كانه ولد عمره ثلاث
سنين ومن وقتها حطيت بعقله انه بدي اتعلم
هالشي وكملت وكثير عملت
ريسورتش اتطلع سافر اقرا تعلم احكي حتى مع
ديزاينر مع عرس امين
طريقه رسمه هي ما فيها كتيرز كل واحد
بتطلع على اللوحه وهو بقرر وين هاي الطريق
او مين في بقلبها وكل واحد بيعمل هو
تفسيره للوحه هذا اللي بحبه
بلشت اول شيء بمحلات انه انا بحب اكون
موجود مثلا الطرقات ببريز مثل
بحبها عندي عن لبنان عن جونيه جبال القديم
تبع جبال
الطول تبعي كتير هي سكينه وحده وشقفه
والالوان
[موسيقى]
السفر والاشتياق لمنطقه معينه او الاستياق
للحظه معينه هذا اللي خلاني جرب طلع هالشي
مني وحطه على اللوحه الرسم هو لحظه معينه
ركزوا على لحظات فيها سعاده بحياتكم وهيدي
بتغير الشخصيه بتغير طريقه التفكير بتغير
حتى طريقه الحياه
[موسيقى]